three-two-one what do we believe there
is a better life waiting for us somebody
else somewhere else I'm happy you made
the choice to come in two days later let
me tell you about identical we help
customers look for that person who looks
like them talks like the walks like the
blank slate on which to write a brand
new here there is only one rule you must
take nothing of your old life with you
feel like I've seen your face before
and rules a ghost later
you're looking in the wrong direction
that always makes things complicated
I can see you're going to take to this
like a duck to water
don't you wanna know who I am
there's a better life waiting for us
somebody else
somewhere else
we're cooling in a loan on your current
life